je prends du minist merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour pour ce débat et pour
la qualité de vos interventions je
voudrais remercier monsieur bertrand
pour le soutien exigeant qu'il a
formulées au nom du groupe rdse
remercier monsieur le sénateur de zocato
pour le soutien vigilant formulée au
programme du gouvernement et pour sa
conclusion en forme d'encouragement
remercier monsieur le sénateur guillaume
pour sa vigilance et son exigence dont
j'ai compris qu'elle pourrait peut-être
prendre la forme d'un soutien
peut-être et peut-être aussi et
peut-être aussi pour m'avoir permis de
constater que les échanges entre les
bancs de cette assemblée pouvait valoir
en termes de chaleur la forme qu'il
prenne sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale
j'aimerais remercier monsieur le
sénateur d'allier d'avoir indiqué ce que
je crois profondément que le
parlementaire tous les parlementaires
étaient des élus de la nation et que le
nom de leur groupe ne déterminait pas à
une forme d'exclusive qui
n'appartiendrait qu'à eux
qu'il se déclare constructif ou autre
chose je suis tellement d'accord avec
vous monsieur le sénateur que en son
temps j'avais été le seul membre de ma
famille politique à voter contre le
choix du nom les républicains car je
pensais que il ne fallait pas prétendre
à l'exclusive en la matière et donc je
vous retrouve volontiers sur ce point
vrai remercier monsieur le sénateur
rachline qu'il m'a dit qu'il n'était pas
convaincu
ce qui ne m'a pas surprise qu'il n'a pas
concerné tant nos différences sont
assumés tour et aussi le remercier
d'avoir évoqué la qualité la qualité de
maire puisque ça me permet de vous
rappeler que avant d'être premier
ministre
j'ai été maire pendant sept ans d'une
ville 275 mille habitants d'une ville
populaire d'une ville qui a longtemps
été dirigée par un maire membre du parti
communiste monsieur laurent mais qui ne
l'est plus et qui a eu dont j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être le maire à partir de
2010 est réélu au premier tour en 2014
une ville pauvre monsieur rachline
populaire industriel fier de ce
qu'allait qui connaît à la fois la
dureté de l'histoire et la dureté des
transformations économiques
cette ville c'est la mienne j'en suis
fier je vous remercie d'avoir pu me
permettre de le mentionner devant vous
je voudrais remercier monsieur le
sénateur patriat de son soutien carré
est complet et sans réserve
ce qui n'exclut je le sais ni l'exigence
et la vigilance et je voudrais remercier
monsieur le sénateur le rang pour
l'opposition assumer et si j'ose dire
aussi carré est complète mais en
symétrique de celle formulée par votre
collègue monsieur patriat un mot
peut-être puisque beaucoup de sujets ont
été évoqués pour évoquer la situation
financière et budgétaire et je voudrais
m'excuser si je ne réponds pas à tous
les sujets qui ont été mentionnés je me
rassure en disant que dans les mois dans
les années qui viennent
l'ensemble de ces sujets seront évoqués
dans le détail et permettront de rentrer
point par point dans les thèmes que vous
avez souhaité évoquer aujourd'hui un mot
peut-être sur la situation financière et
budgétaire en disant que le rapport de
la cour des comptes de ma famille en
colère plus exactement il ne m'a pas
donné envie de chercher le des coupables
et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il nous faille chercher des coupables
en tout cas c'est pas le terrain sur
lequel je me place je pense même que
d'une certaine façon nous ferions bien
de commencer par assumer le fait que
nous avons en la matière des
responsabilités partagées
on peut dire certains plus que d'autres
peut-être peut-être peut-être mais je
suis né en 1970 et à partir de 1974
aucun gouvernement n'a voté un budget en
équilibre et lieux des gouvernements de
droite et ils ont fait du mieux qu'il
pouvait il ya du gouvernement de gauche
ils ont probablement fait du mieux qu'il
pouvait n'empêche qu'à la fin mesdames
et messieurs nous nous retrouvons dans
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec 2200 2147 à la fin de
l'année probablement de 1200 milliards
de dettes publiques aujourd'hui avec des
dépenses effectivement non financées sur
l'année 2010 est à hauteur de 8
milliards et j'observe pour être
parfaitement précis que le la cour des
comptes ne dit pas ne dis pas que le
déficit de l'année 2017 sera de 3,2 elle
dit que le déficit de l'année 2017 sera
de 3 2%
si nous prenons des mesures énergiques
c'est à dire qu'en réalité il est au
dessus de 3,2 il ya effectivement un
dérapage y compris parmi eux y compris
au regard des prévisions les plus
pessimistes qui avait été formulée
y compris dans cette assemblée jeu j
insiste parce que la formulation de la
cour des comptes n'est pas neutre et
qu'elle est et qu'elle montre la gravité
de la situation
8 milliards de dépenses non financées
j'ajoute à cela un rapport celui du
corps qui alors que l'année dernière je
ne mets pas en cause
je constate alors que l'année dernière
le corps fonder son analyse sur des
hypothèses qui lui permettait de dire
que l'équilibré du système de retraites
serait atteint en 2025 le même corps
chance ces hypothèses pourquoi pas et
nous dit cette année depuis peu
quand vérité le retour à l'équilibré du
système de retraites doit plutôt être
regardée comme pouvant être atteint en
il ya effectivement une différence on
peut sans doute l'analyse et on peut
sans doute discuter le changement des
hypothèses qui conduit à ce décalage de
15 ans enfin je le constate et je me
sens tenus d'y apporter des réponses
nous ne faisons pas de collectif
budgétaire
ça nous indiquons que nous allons tenir
dès 2017 l'objectif de 3%
pourquoi 3% parce que c'est un
engagement qui a été souscrit par la
france pas par la droite
pas par la gauche par la france depuis
longtemps et qui depuis longtemps n'est
pas tenue pour des raisons qui peuvent
expliquer qu'ils peuvent même se
justifier à certains égards mais
reconnaissons là aussi tranquillement
entre nous si j'ose dire que tous les
pays confrontés aux mêmes difficultés
que nous on fait les efforts qui leur
permettait à eux de revenir sous le
seuil qu'ils avaient librement accepté
de tenir vis-à-vis de leurs partenaires
nous sommes les derniers
et ça n'est pas satisfaisant pas parce
que l'hydre bruxellois nous imposerait
sa loi parce que nous n'avons pas
respecté les engagements que nous avons
pris et chacun ici voit bien le problème
qui s'attache à ce qu'un pays comme nous
comme le nôtre ne tienne pas ses
engagements et charge les générations
qui suivront
nos enfants nos petits-enfants de la
responsabilité de rembourser des dettes
c'est à dire ce que nous ne voulons pas
à payer pour nous mêmes et donc nous
avons décidé de respecter ce seuil de 3%
et nous avons décidé de le faire sans
sens collectif budgétaire pour une
raison simple c'est que si nous ouvrions
un collectif budgétaire
nous aurions régler la question du 3% en
augmentant les impôts au je ne le dis
pas parce que je suis plus malin que les
autres je le dis parce que c'est
toujours comme ça que ça a été fait
quand on voit un déficit
il est plus facile de le régler par une
augmentation d'impôts qui se justifie
toujours qui se justifie toujours que
par une réduction des dépenses notre
objectif a été de dire nous
n'augmenterons pas en 2017
les impôts nous allons tenir ce déficit
en réduisant nos dépenses
c'est un effectif c'est un objectif
ambitieux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et nous allons tenir
et puis il y aura 2018
et là encore nous nous sommes engagés à
une maîtrise des dépenses je l' ai dit
hier je le redis aujourd'hui notre
objectif celui qui fixait c'est la
stabilité en volume en volume hors
inflation des dépenses publiques
le pib augmentera le niveau des dépenses
restera identique
quand nous parlons de maîtrise de la
masse salariale dans la fonction
publique nous ne disons pas que nous
allons baisser
évidemment pas le traitement des
fonctionnaires il ya des pays qui l'ont
fait sous la contrainte
jamais de gaieté de coeur mais qu'ils
ont faits qui l'ont fait c'est parce que
nous proposons c'est pas du tout ce que
nous proposons nous disons simplement
qu'il faut par l'organisation de nos
services par la réorganisation de nos
administrations
réussir à faire en sorte d'avoir une
masse salariale stable stable en 2010 8
par rapport à 2010 est est ce que nous
disons au niveau de l'état beaucoup
d'entre vous au niveau local l'ont fait
sans que ce soit simple j'en ai
parfaitement conscience je les fais au
havre et je suis bien persuadé qu'il est
ici un grand nombre d'élus locaux
responsables d'exécutifs se sont fixé
cet objectif d'une stabilité de leur
masse salariale peut être certains ont
été au-delà et on réduit la masse
salariale non pas les rémunérations des
fonctionnaires
l'ensemble des rémunérations ce qui
permet de réduire un peu la masse
salariale certains l'ont fait c'est
l'objectif que nous fixons à l'ensemble
des administrations publiques à
l'ensemble des fonctions publiques c'est
un objectif dont je sais bien qu'il est
difficile à atteindre mais c'est
l'objectif que nous nous fixons en 2018
nous augmenterons la csg en contrepartie
d'une diminution des charges et des
cotisations salariales et sociales il
c'est un choix politique il ne devrait
surprendre personne il a été présenté
pendant la campagne électorale il a été
validé par les français pendant la
présidentielle
et pendant la législative on peut être
contre je ne conçois parfaitement mais
personne ne peut être surpris par cela
et l'objectif au fond est simple il
résulte d'un choix assumé politique qui
consiste à dire dans notre pays
aujourd'hui il faut redonner
du pouvoir d'achat à ceux qui
travaillent ça ne veut pas dire ça ne
veut pas dire que on ne s'intéresse pas
à tous les autres mais ça veut dire que
si on veut relancer l'activité dans
notre pays si on veut relancer la
création de richesse si on veut faire
repartir notre pays il faut avoir une
attention permanente pour ceux qui
créent la richesse
quel que soit d'ailleurs le domaine
d'activité il dit ah les salariés il ya
aussi les indépendants les indépendants
paient des cotisations sociales
ils bénéficieront eux aussi de cette
disposition un mot pour dire que dès la
fin de l'année 2017 dans une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nous voterons l'ensemble du dispositif
fiscal des années à venir
pour une raison simple c'est que et là
encore chacun le sait lorsque nous
rencontrons des chefs d'entreprise
lorsque nous rencontrons des acteurs du
monde économique
ce qu'ils nous disent souvent c'est que
au fond ils n'attendent pas le grand
soir fiscal etc en revanche ils ont
besoin de visibilité et de lisibilité et
de prévisibilité et que au fond il ya un
prix presque plus important encore à
savoir comment ça va se passer qu'à
obtenir immédiatement quelque chose dont
on sait que ça ne sera pas crédible et
nous savons tous et c'est bien parce que
nous savons tous que à la fin de l'année
nous ferons voter cette loi qui nous
permettra d'avoir précisément pour
l'année 2010 8 pour l'année 2010 9 pour
l'année 2020 le chemin fiscal qui sera
fixé et qui sera respecté
c'est pas du tout neutre et c'est dans
ce cadre que nous allons indiqué après
en avoir débattu et que le parlement
bien entendu que nous allons indiquer la
façon dont nous allons modifier le
dispositif fiscal et dont nous allons
point par point et sur chacun des sujets
respecter les objectifs et les mesures
annoncées par le président de l'udc
reste le sujet dont j'ai compris qu'il
était un sujet important mais je le
savais
de la taxe d'habitation est peut-être
plus généralement encore le sujet du
lien entre le territoire et la recette
fiscale
je vous retrouve là encore sur ce sujet
il se trouve que peut-être parce que
j'étais maire et président d'une
agglomération très industrielle mais pas
parlementaire à l'époque j'avais moi
même formulé des grands doutes sur une
des réformes anciennes pour je ne me
souviens plus lorsqu'elle a été adoptée
qui consistait à modifier et a supprimé
la taxe professionnelle pour la
remplacer par quelque chose qui était
une subvention quasiment parce que
justement on couper le lien entre les
territoires industriels dans lesquels
des investissements importants avec des
contreparties pour le territoire été
réalisés et qu'on le remplaçait par
quelque chose c'est une réforme en ciel
elle est là on reviendra pas dessus
parce que l'instabilité fiscale est
insupportable mais je vous rejoins assez
volontiers de monsieur le sénateur sur
le fait que trop couper le lien entre la
ressource fiscale et le territoire
présente des inconvénients
ça n'interdit pas ça n'interdit pas de
réfléchir dans ce cadre à ce que j'ai
indiqué d'abord en diminuant la taxe
d'habitation pour des gens qui ont
besoin pour des français qui veulent
récupérer du pouvoir d'achat et ensuite
à plus long terme peut-être c'est vrai
en repensant un bon système fiscal local
c'est-à-dire fondamentalement un système
qui permet à la fois de prendre en
compte les revenus et les richesses et
les spécificités des territoires y
compris parfois à l'intérieur même d'une
commune car tous ceux qui connaissent
les finances aux municipales savent
combien l'impossibilité de moduler en
fonction des quartiers un certain nombre
de taux est susceptible justement de
d'accroître les inégalités à l'intérieur
d'une commune sur la durée
on aura donc cette réflexion on aura
donc eu cette discussion et sera ouverte
elle sera conduite par le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
elle permettra des échanges directs et
évidemment il n'est pas le lieu ni le
moment de trancher
ce n'est pas le moment ce sera
probablement le lieu mais ça n'est pas
le moment
c'est ça ça n'est pas le moment mais ce
sera le lieu et on aura cette discussion
très complète
mais à la fin de ce premier la chance je
voudrais mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président vous
remercier vivement et vous dire que j'ai
hâte de travailler avec vous merci
beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]